Hi Mike, how are you?
It's Frank Defratus.
Hey, Frank.
How are you doing tonight?
Just fine and yourself?
Doing good.
Okay.
Why don't we start off by having you tell people what this project that you're interested in is a m is about and how you got interested in these holographic optical elements.
Well, um this started in a strange way, which is really uh not so strange considering that it's understood that most of the advancements of any particular field come 95% of the as they say of the advancements of any field come from people outside of the field.
Uh-huh.
And uh that was sort of my ex experience.
Uh what happened was I was in the solar field and I uh I was in Hawaii and acting as a um uh for PRI Pacific Resources International, the commercial energy sales division.
I was considered to be an energy management specialist.
Okay.
And um DOE was having one of their last uh evaluations and uh think tanks on these large 30 foot diameter parabolic dishes for uh solar electric generators.
Concent they're sort of like concentrators, right?
Yeah, mostly front surface mirrored systems.
Yeah.
Um I was that was um a very fascinating um effort for me.
That was my first think tank.
And I was really learning a lot.
I was I was really awestruck by all of the work done by um groups mostly throughout the US.
Um and I uh I learned um at some of these meetings that well it's not my uh position just to say, oh wow, these are great but rather I'm supposed to look for bugs.
Um the the objective was to try to find what systems would work best in um different conditions.
And of course in Hawaii um the um the weather there is is different than um most other places in that about every twenty minutes these high vertical tropical clouds would go by and it would disturb the performance of these front surface mirrored parabolic dishes that were used to uh concentrate sunlight on a point um because the uh clouds would uh cover up the mirror and and there would be a a bright cloud maybe over to the right or the left.
It would it would it would basically diffuse the uh sunlight.
Uh yeah, actually uh the because they were extremely high vertical tropical clouds they would act as mirrors.
So it would uh the the sun would be blocked out and the the uh the dish uh the parabolic dish would think that the sun would be over to the right or l or the left and it would jockey over one direction or the other.
Oh okay.
And uh sometimes a a a shadow would fall on the dish and it would it would go into the stove position thinking that it was going to rain or something.
So these dishes would work great out in the desert in in areas where there's not a lot of clouds but they um wouldn't fare very well where the majority of the inhabited population of the earth live.
But anyway, um I uh realized that those systems would work great in the desert but they wouldn't find um much use in areas where the majority of the po of the world's population lives.
Um now um solar scientists have realized um uh years prior to that that in uh most of the inhabited areas that the majority of the available energy um that's coming at at um uh these areas is in the diffuse forum in the summertime uh there's a um um a lot of direct uh radiation but in the winter time it's it's mostly cloudy so uh most of these panels would work fine in the summer but not so good in the winter when you needed it.
Okay.
So um I uh I just asked the proverbial question what if what if we had some type of a concentrator system that could gather both the direct and the diffuse components and realizing that on an annual basis um in a lot of the populated area you can uh see that the diffuse content is half or more just over half in a lot of places.
So if you could come up with an optical concentrator or a new magnifying glass that could collect both then you would essentially double the performance of these collector apparatuses.
And and hence you turn to uh holographic optical elements HOEs.
Well first um I didn't know about hose um so I just did a um um a rectilinear or a geometrical um uh ray tracing um uh search if you will to see if if it could be done and I just worked with a little twenty dollar TI uh scientific calculator and a um pencil and a ruler and a protractor and um in a couple of weeks I uh came up with a design and one of the guys on the think tank was teaching optical physics at the University of Hawaii um uh Manoa um I believe it's called uh Manoa campus just up the hill from Waikiki.
I think Steve Michael did some holography work out in the out in Hawaii as well but go ahead.
So um I uh I asked him uh if he would check my work to see if if I was doing this right I was just using Snell's law uh to do this ray tracing and um he looked at it and he just he just dropped his jaw and he he just thought my goodness he thought this this thing is so simple why why didn't we do this before?
And he we we were in his office.
He had this little uh not much more than a cubicle a little little office at the university there and he was just seemingly prancing around saying, gee, he says, I can see this has laser application and I looked at him dumbfoundedly and and he says this has fiber optic applications and I said, Well I really don't know much about that and he says he says well this has applications in all transmitters and receivers and I told him well I really don't know much about that.
I was just trying to make a new magnifying glass that could catch the diffuse component.
So he says, Well, he says, you showed me a two D he says, Can you do it in three D And I I um I was showing him some of my work, the progression of my work, and I flipped a few more pages and I said, Well yeah it's gonna look something like this and he said that's it.
So I told him I said, well let me uh finish this drawing and I'll bring it back to you and I'll show ya.
Uh so I called him in a week or two and um I said, Well uh do you have time to see me to take a look at this and he says, Oh man he says do you have time?
He says I've been talking to my friend.
So they want to talk to you and he says I took the liberty to call DOE and everybody's excited and so forth.
So I went to see him and um he says well look he says they want you to go back to the mainland um and so I did and I flew back to Denver and I met with a fella Howard Coleman that was head of the DOE solar thermal um solar thermal program and uh Howard says look Mike he says we've had a look at this and we realize what you've got um he says I want to introduce you to Larry Shannon who was head of the Sierra and he says Larry will uh walk you through this and uh we really want to uh help you develop this.
Okay.
Um but to make a long story short, what happened was they found other applications and I was um well they asked me to sign these non disclosure statements and uh they gave me kind of a rough time and uh what it was was people from DOD.
Oh I see.
So anyway at that time this was the days of SDI and uh Reagan Star Wars and and so many things with with the name optics tagged to it was kept secret for a while until they could figure out what to do with it.
I'm surprised the aliens didn't have this technology already in their spacecraft that they have.
I'm just kidding.
Go ahead.
Um so anyway, I um I went on to other things.
I I I really wanted to know what they meant about these other applications, so that encouraged me to I went out to uh Pasadena City College and there's a uh two year program out there with Wayne and Lou they used to have a laser electro optics program and that's where I took um um a couple of holography classes to learn about hose and and to realize that this could be done by diffraction as well as refraction.
Um so I um I did it the hard way if you will I I spent it was like working on a puzzle I spent several hours each night to to work with lens design to r to realize that this could be done by refraction.
And so I think it all the way through it helped me realize in a rectilinear geometrical way um uh the needed character or design of of optical systems um which I guess is a little bit different approach than um what a lot of folks in the field of optics take.
What were some of the applications that came out of this the practical applications in use?
Well um uh of course um it's for uh as a multiplexer.
Mm-hmm.
And um that would be for fiber optic communication, right?
Yeah, uh-huh.
Well I guess it's it's you know, I I really couldn't name all the applications.
My focus was on mostly um solar and um I uh I looked at a a lot of domestic applications.
Now I remember reading quite a while ago, and I believe this might have been through the University of Pennsylvania, where they did some greenhouse experiment with hoe panels, and um apparently if you were to stand in the greenhouse, even though the sun would be transversing the sky, according to the plants, and from the plants perspective, the sun always remained overhead.
Is is that fairly accurate?
Yeah, that was a uh a Dr.
White um who set up three greenhouses, uh one with clear glass, um next one with uh a regular frosted glass, and the third with uh holographic um uh or hoe covered glasses.
And uh what they realized was the plants with the clear glass they drew they grew tall and skinny, and the ones with the the cloudy glass they grew significantly better.
Um they were more robust and not as tall and much more plant weight and all the good things that you would like to see with plants.
Yeah, they were more full, I believe.
Yeah, and they could be harvested uh more easily.
Um and the and the the ones with the hose were even better than just the cloudy glass.
Yeah, they I think they exhibited the qualities of both.
They were they were they grew very tall, but they also grew very full.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
So um I what my objective with is with all of this is to try to find um folks in the field of philography that would be interested in um kicking this back off again.
I just let it lay for about ten years.
Mm-hmm.
Um and I'm interested in um I've got a little project going right now.
The first of this year I met um a well over the phone I met uh uh uh Jock Ludman and uh John Caulfield who were working in a related area.
Um they um attempted I I don't know how far they got, but they attempted to start a company called Daylight Saving, which uses the same uh principle.
I think Jock Ludman acting develop uh actually developed those hoes for the greenhouse for uh Dr.
White over at Penn State.
But uh what That's a great company name, Daylight Savings.
Yeah, they think that there's gonna be um uh lots of money involved with providing uh appropriate daylighting in buildings.
Yeah, they're I I believe they're already in use in architecture in different areas.
Uh yeah, but it's not really um fully taken advantage of.
And and they're hoping to start a big marketing effort and um provide I think they actually got a contract with a uh university down in Waco, Texas to to put on um maybe even hundreds of thousands of square feet of these hose to uh direct the light in the appropriate direction.
But the problem is is that um with uh so called path of solar or or um windows and even on the east and west side, uh the light um from the sun gets to be kinda aggravating if uh people throw up curtains.
Uh it with passive solar uh what happens is the it's it's sort of like driving west in the afternoon and the sun is in your eyes and it really uh throws a lot of glare and it's it's it's not very appealing.
It's it's not good for as we say visual acuity.
It's it's it's literally harming your eyes.
Consequently people um um haven't um been really fully utilizing passive solar um because of that.
So could you envision this being placed within a car windshield that would divert that um direct sunlight.
Uh yeah I I think not only um uh directing the light um through the window but also uh line of sight maybe.
Uh yeah and also uh maybe directing the light within the window.
Um uh John Caulfield got a patent on um edge lighting for um for holograms.
Mm-hmm.
And um there's this this law of reversibility if you look at um a as the as we say an optical train with some lens system um it if the input side um the light will traverse throughout this this uh track of uh lenses and so forth and come out at the output side and if you throw it in the light in the exact opposite direction it will it will end up where the input um or the incident ray um was introduced.
Mm-hmm this law of reversibility so um when John Caulfield uh came up with this idea of these edge lit or at least he got the patent on the edge lit holograms um I realized right away Wolf G this could be used for solar hose to fiber couple to bring the light down to um wherever to storage or immediate use.
Yeah.
This edgelit technology was that uh originally developed to illuminate holographic images, those types of holograms or was this more of an a a panel where you could uh introduce the light source at the edge and then have the panel actually radiate that light outward?
Well I think it was used uh mostly for a holographic display okay okay yeah hmm so I um I just realized that it could also be used for for um uh solar holograms and and uh transmitting the light down to where you need it.
Mm-hmm.
Uh you're getting a lab set up to do this.
If someone had a lab, say uh amateur hobbyist telographer, they may have a four by eight foot sand table, you know, in their home or wherever it happens to be, how could they make a simple holographic optical element with a helium neon laser in a simple setup for demonstration purposes or just for learning?
Well um I the way I look at it is the direction that you want this lens or this this hode to throw the light is uh the direction at which you provide lighting to expose the hologram.
Mm-hmm.
So we we'd need two beams.
We'd need a reference beam and then we'd also need an object beam, and I imagine both of those are sent to the holographic plate and then the uh the grating is uh created and is that then used as the holographic optical element?
Can you use that with white light or does it have to be monochromatic laser light as well in order for it to work?
Uh you mean to to expose the hologram.
Well, yeah, you need monochromatic to expose it, but once it's exposed, um is it a is it a laser transmission hologram, white light transmission hologram?
Do you know happen to know what steps would need to be taken?
Well, it's a it's a transmission hologram.
Yeah.
Um and um you know, I'm not really familiar with the way uh John Ludman set up his for Penn State.
Mm-hmm.
But um I um I uh I believe that it it should be done just as a um a regular setup for a transmission hologram.
Yeah, just a regular split beam hologram, but instead of illuminating an object to use the object beam to uh just come into the holographic plate along with the reference beam, I would imagine.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
So what are your plans with this?
What are you going to do with it?
Well, I've got an application right now.
I'm putting together a building with uh passive solar windows, and um I um I'm I'm going to cover the windows with these diffraction gratings to throw the light up against the ceiling.
Mm-hmm.
Do you have do you have a website by the way?
Uh no, I don't.
I I'm actually I'm I'm putting together information um and I I I will shortly create a website.
I do have an email address.
Yeah.
I'm gonna make sure that you I'm gonna make sure that your email address is on the website so when people listen to this if they want to contact you, they can send you an email.
It's an interesting what, Mac dot com.
Are you on a Mac?
Uh yes I am.
Interesting.
I'm I've yeah, go ahead.
It's just my name.
It's Mike Hingle.
It's uh H I N G L E at Mac dot com.
Okay.
Now now if you look at this this field of energy or solar energy, um uh what I used to teach you solar classes down at uh Pasadena City College in Tucson for um three years in ninety, ninety one and ninety two.
And uh and also some energy classes for DOE and HUD, uh residential energy auditing.
And uh what we used to talk about uh was the the magnitude of the problem.
If you look at um the um energy our energy problem in the world, we realize that um of all the money that the world makes, um or all your effort uh for sustaining life if you will, that sixty to seventy percent of your cost of living goes to the energy business.
Mm-hmm.
And most people think, well, it's just my electric bill and my gasoline bill.
Um but um there's a hidden energy tax in everything that we do.
And there's a good example is say a cotton t shirt.
Um if you look at the energy involved in production producing that t shirt, you have to plant the seed that takes energy.
You have to plow the field that takes energy, you have to um you have to fertilize and the fertilizer has to be manufactured through uh energy.
Right.
So if you even want to take it a step back.
You have to irrigate, that takes energy.
You you have to harvest the field and refine the cotton and transport it and uh then the refined material you have to sew it together and make clothes make the t shirt out of it, and then uh the workers drive back and forth and they put it in a warehouse, usually air conditioned, and then it goes into a store and people drive to the store to pick it up, and so you can see that the majority of the cost of that t shirt is energy.
The the cotton is just a little bit of seed.
Um that's very interesting.
Yeah, and that goes with all goods and services.
Everything that you can if that you look around your room and you see the majority of the cost, as they say, sixty to seventy percent of everybody's cost of living, first, second and third world countries is energy.
So it's a hidden tax.
It's an energy tax.
So it's the world's biggest enslavery, if you will, and that's why there's so much um tension, if you will, over uh petroleum resources, because um the the world's economy is wrapped up in energy.
Yeah, I I did a hologram one time with the solar panel.
I put it outside of the uh lab window here and I just fed it into one of the um laser diodes and ran the laser diode in the middle of the day when the sun was hitting the solar panel and just got free energy to run the diode.
I felt pretty neat about it.
That was neat.
I like that.
Well, I think that we can take it a lot further.
I I believe that um you know, if if you look at your your end uses for energy.
It doesn't matter if it's oil or or gasoline or natural gas or coal or nuclear or whatever or solar, you we we use it really for we could say only three purposes.
And um really four, but you you need light.
You need heat, or just the opposite of that is cool.
And you need shaft power.
You know, you're turning a mixer or a blender or maybe your uh your the wheels in your car or something.
So you need light, heat and shaft power and then of course there's communication.
Um and so uh the question is well can we do this with photonics instead of electronics and the answer is yes.
Yeah.
Um what's his name Lauren uh the guy that uh started the photonics spectra back in nineteen fifty four.
Oh, not sure of the name.
Um Teddy Lauren I believe.
Okay.
Um he uh wrote a neat statement uh in um some time in the late nineties saying that the um the workhorse that propelled us in the uh twentieth century to this high industrialization and uh information society was the electron.
Mm-hmm.
And in the decade of the nineties we found that virtually everything that we did with the electron could be done better and smaller and faster and much safer and without interference or whatever with the photon.
And so they see that the twenty first century will be driven by photonics instead of electronics.
Mm-hmm.
Um and Photons photons traveling through the computer circuits instead of actual electrons.
Right, Bell Labs and IBM and uh I I forgot who all but uh back in even I think maybe the mid eighties was the first total photonics computers.
They're just lab models to to see if it would work.
And um uh what's his name?
Schwarzkopf the guy that headed up the uh Persian Gulf of War one uh just days a couple of days after um the war was over he was in Congress saying see what we did with this photonics technology he says now uh we need more money because we want to have a total photonics fighting force by the year two thousand so uh you know hence there was a lot of uh interest uh for military applications and so a lot of the domestic applications were hidden.
But if you really think about it and that's what I'm trying to encourage people in this holida uh holography field to do is to think about it is you you can realize that virtually everything we do for lighting, for heating, for cooking, for refrigeration, for shaft power, everything we do with electronics we really can do and even um I believe simpler with photonics.
I believe there are some photonic stoves now.
Am I correct with that?
I I what is I think they're based on halogen technology but it's uh using light to cook on not familiar with that.
I do I do know that they're pretty they're they're fairly pricey but I think they're out there.
Well what happens now with the cooking for instance um you put a pot on the stove it's either electric burner or a gas burner typically and um you cook some meal in it and typically um ninety five percent of the heat of that cooking job just goes out into the room.
Only five percent actually gets put into the the food.
Mm-hmm.
And so if you use um um maybe a vacuum jacket and um uh use a uh on the uh the the the inside of this vacuum if you use total reflective and and totally absorbing surfaces uh then you might say we have like a diode or a one way mirror system so that we can make sure that ninety five percent of the heat stays in the pot.
And so this is actually being done.
There's a group out of um England someplace that had one of these thirty minute uh T V commercials that showed this uh looks like a pressure cooker that what they do and it had some valve on the top with an indicator that um they put um you know how they do they put these meals maybe a roast with some potatoes in there and some greens and whatever else they throw a whole bunch of stuff in the pot and uh they brought the in just a couple of minutes they brought the pot up to uh some working temperature and when some um uh some indicator um showed that it was it was at the desired temperature then they picked up the pot with their bare hands because it was vacuum jacketed and it had these um mirrored systems um and they put it in the the ice box okay freezer and a couple of hours later they pulled it out and everything was done to perfection.
You know how they show that on heat yes yes.
Okay, so what that did was they didn't show what it was, but I knew what it was because I had already been doing some design of those type of systems, domestic systems, showing that yes we can do that.
What we learned in the field of optics um is especially in a lot of these critical maybe space applications for uh cryogenically cooled sensors or whatever that you need to employ that degree of sophistication for uh systems.
Well anytime you increase efficiency, you also increase savings.
Do you think there's some sort of a conspiracy going on that we're not seeing these technologies move more rapidly?
Well, we need it for defense so that we can uh beat the putting out of these other countries for their the remaining oil.
Mm-hmm.
I see.
Maybe that's what it is.
It seems to be um of a situation.
But you know, I think that uh what we need to do is uh g um I think we're just too darn comfortable and we don't have enough people thinking in this direction.
Mm-hmm.
That the technology is there and uh if we if we work together on this, we could really change the world.
We you know, I I've seen the light.
I think we can bring this out and uh change everything for the better.
I've seen the light.
That's that's a great way.
Mike, we've run up to thirty minutes.
I want to try and keep it at thirty minutes.
So is there anything you'd like to close things out with?
Well, I would just like to see a team effort.
You know, I would like to see um talented people in this field come together and to um set up a a goal, a project with a goal and and to start develop uh this this technology, domestic use of cotonics technology.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
I want to thank you very much for coming on the show.
Well, thank you.
I'll have this up uh probably over the holiday weekend and send an announcement out and uh make sure that uh your downloadable documents are there and also your email address and anyone who would like to contact you can do so.
Great.
All right.
Well, thank you, Frank.
Mike, I want to thank you very much for taking the time to be on the show and I'll talk to you soon, okay?
Have a happy turkey day.
Same to you.
Bye.